mr general always good to see you uh
particularly this
early hour um we've got a lot to talk
about on your brief but
can we just start with the the issues
such as they may be
around vaccination why has there been an
instruction a change to the schedule
in terms of vaccination how much of a
delay do we see being built into the
system
well we do think there are going to be
some supply issues in the weeks ahead
but this isn't anything that people
should be worried about we're still on
course
to meet our targets that's to vaccinate
all of the groups one to nine by the
middle of april and all adults to
receive
their first vaccine by the end of july
nobody who has an appointment should be
concerned
you're still going to get your second
vaccine all those appointments will be
honored
but we always said right from the
beginning that a new manufacturing
process would have its lumps and bumps
and that has been the case in the past
and
i'm sure it will be in the future we're
sourcing vaccines from all over the
world and
we are experiencing occasionally some
issues and that's led to this
uh this issue with some supply in the
coming weeks but
as i say the main thing is we're still
very much on course we've still got line
of sight
to deliver the vaccines and to meet our
targets
just to be really specific and indeed on
something you just mentioned there
problems in obtaining the vaccine from
around the world there's a suggestion
this morning that perhaps the
the issue as regards the the az oxford
vaccine it is a problem in india where
where they do produce is that
is that your understanding well i'm not
going to get into
the specific contracts that we have with
different manufacturers
we're sourcing vaccines from many
countries all over the world
it's a very complex international supply
chain and as i say
that does mean occasionally we will
experience issues and and that is what
we've experienced right now but there is
no reason to be concerned
we are on course to meet our target
which is to get those first categories
of one to nine
vaccinated by the middle of april and
that was always a challenging target
remember we only met our target in
mid-february
with a couple of days grace and so the
targets the prime minister has set us
are not easy ones but we are on course
uh to
to to to achieve that one and myself
matt hancock nadeem zahawi
the government we have line of sight
that we've got enough vaccines
to do that and so that's the main thing
and that's what we're focused on right
now
indeed and of course as you as you've do
as you alluded to the health sector
yesterday in in downing street made it
very clear that those
those deadlines those targets would
would still be met there is a little bit
of concern though
on whether or not this might have some
impact uh
on the road map itself i mean is the is
the
is the map roadmap actually based on
those kind of confirmed vaccination
targets on those dates that the
the health secretary still stuck to
yesterday
well the the vaccine rollout is our
route out of this
the more people we vaccinate the easier
it will be to open up our society and
get us back to
the way of life that we all want to see
there's no reason to believe that the
roadmap
is affected by uh this temporary
shortage
in supply uh the the main thing is that
we are
on course to meet the targets of the
prime minister set us up getting uh
the categories one to nine which is all
the over 50s including the
the clinically extremely vulnerable
below that age vaccinated by
the middle of april so there's no
concern that uh we're off course with
the road capture
just one last question on the vaccine
and it is a distance from your brief so
you may well not know this
but does the madonna jab start coming
into circulation
uh in april i don't know
to be honest the the exact date that uh
the modern chap will be in use within
the uk uh obviously we have uh the
orders placed
and uh we'll be using them as quickly as
they they come into the country
i actually apolo apologies that
secretaries did i i i
inadvertently misspoke that one more
question on on the vaccines
what what do you make of the the saber
rattling that we're seeing from amongst
others ursula wonderland
the the threat that somehow that the the
eu could have a rather spurious
interpretation to my eyes at least of
article 22
and intervene in vaccinations and
delivery of vaccines that we have
bought that we have paid for that are on
contractual basis hours
that the eu might step in to intervene
there
well i was surprised and disappointed by
those comments but the prime minister
had spoken earlier in the year to ursula
vanderlian and she gave a very clear
commitment
which was that uh the eu would not
engage in this sort of activity
that contractual responsibilities would
be honoured
and that's exactly what we intend to do
and i i hope and expect
the eu to to stick to their side of the
bargain as well it isn't at all helpful
if we enter into this sort of
conversation that's not the way the uk
is behaving or wants to behave in the
future we all need to work together
to get through this supplies of vaccines
rely on very complex
international manufacturing supply
chains as we've just said
and so everybody needs to uh to have
free trade
vaccines and not get into this sort of
this sort of difficulty
um talk to us a little bit then about
about rough sleeping the rough sleeping
accommodation program of course did
serve to take thousands of people off of
the streets at a time when
you know everyone was very very
concerned about the spread of the
pandemic we certainly knew a lot less
and
we're moving on to the second stage of
that now
that's right a year ago uh almost to the
day we launched everyone in which
had a simple objective of asking those
people who are sleeping rough on the
streets are most vulnerable to covered
19
to come into safe and secure
accommodation it was hugely successful
we ended up bringing in over 37 000
people who are either sleeping on the
streets or in otherwise pretty
precarious situations like sofa surfing
with friends
and relatives most of those people have
now been able to move on into better
accommodation
either social housing the private rental
sector or what's called move on
accommodation
which is temporary with accommodation
with wrap around care
about 27 000 people have been given that
sort of help over the course of the last
year
but we still got many people in
temporary emergency accommodation
and today we're putting in place further
support
so that we can build up good quality
accommodation to help those people to
access it and begin to rebuild their
lives we've secured over 400 million
pounds
and today we're releasing the next 200
million of that so the
charities and local councils across the
country can invest in
up to 6 000 new move on units over the
course of this parliament and that will
give us
a new national asset of accommodation so
that if people are sleeping rough
they can be moved on given a home and
then begin to
rebuild their lives yeah get help for
substance abuse
there will be no one who is what sorry
apologies minutes we've got a finite
amount of time there will be no one
working in this sector that will not
welcome additional money of course
they will welcome additional money the
question is whether or not it goes quite
so far
quite far enough i mean the statistics
as you were mentioning there 37 and a
half thousand people
in essence helped in uh as a result of
everyone in but that
i mean that figure there is obviously
going to be a disparity but that figure
of 37 and a half thousand
is a country mile away from the
department's own estimates of
of how many rough sleepers there were in
the country it was roughly 4
300 in march 2020. i mean you've been on
a bit of a learning curve here
but are we still on course to eradicate
homelessness by
2024 yes i think we are
by that we mean that nobody should have
to sleep rough
on the streets i think we've learned
from everyone in that there will always
be some people
who do for a variety of complex reasons
even at the height of
the lockdown last spring when we asked
everybody in the country who was
sleeping rough on the streets
to come in we still found a small number
of people who chose not to
but our objective is that there is good
care that everybody is offered
accommodation
within at least a night or so of being
seen on the streets and that is what
we're working towards we made huge
progress
last year the number of people sleeping
rough on the streets fell by about 37
according to the statistics that were
published a month ago
that's a major step forward but there
will be big challenges ahead
and the strategy that we are putting in
place is not just one of housing
but it is also one of health making sure
there is proper support for people for
their mental health
and for substance abuse which is a
really significant factor
in why people end up on the streets and
then
the the issues that they face when
they're on the streets
okay minister just just before just
before we we wrap up um
there's a a policy initiative i think
from pretty patel that will raise a few
eyebrows uh during the rounds this
morning few reports
that asylum seekers could be sent from
the united kingdom asylum seekers who
have arrived in the united kingdom
could be sent to to third countries
to have their asylum uh application
process
what is the thinking behind this and
then in what way will this
deter people from making the journey to
the uk in the first place
well this isn't uh a uh announced by the
home sector there's a speculation on
work that she is doing
and uh we'll be saying more on in the
weeks ahead so
i i can't give you all the answers this
morning but it is extremely important
that we have a robust immigration system
and
those people coming to the country to
seek asylum can do so
in safety we don't want anyone's lives
to be put at risk we don't want people
to be at the hands of
people traffickers we've seen people
including young children
dying making perilous crossings across
the channel
that isn't something that we want to see
and so if there are safer and better
ways of doing that
then we should be exploring them and
that's exactly what the home secretary
is doing